hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
clip titled heated debate from the fresh
and fit
after hours podcast if you like this
video
do not forget to like comment and
subscribe
also let me know what videos i should do
next
because i'm like running out of clips of
stuff that i want to do
so let me know in the comments but
let's see
okay going to fresh fit podcast
after hours edition we're joined by
three lovely ladies oh my god this is
three hours why do they do this to me
why
let's get into it guys it's gonna be a
good club
[Music]
kind of like complicated i'm definitely
more like a personality
all right well she's like the one and
only you'll be one of the first so
you're telling me you've never hooked up
with a guy the same night you met him
even in college
correct okay not all the way sex what
have you like made
out or anything like that yeah like okay
making out yeah like that doesn't really
count
okay okay i mean but you've never like
banged them
i'll tell you the nose that i've done
i'll give you some juice that you want
okay sure i do like to give lap dances
in the club
if i'm in the club literally in the club
wait so so
so she's a huge [ __ ] tease so hold on
so let me get this straight you you've
never hooked up with a guy on the first
date but you give him a lap dance that's
his that's his like little treat
a lot of dance i like to laugh dance
yeah but what does he
but what about him that sucks
he should be happy he even got this
friends what are you talking about i
make him look good
okay oh i mean look good feel good bro
if a chick told me i'm gonna give you a
lap dance i would look at her like
stupid nah get out of here but um okay
all right i guess that's uh
she never had a one-eyed stand and she
gives lap dances to guys on the first
night
further she's gonna go like lap dance
okay what about
relationships then what do i look for in
a relationship
yeah i don't know that's kind of like
complicated
i'm definitely more like a personality
kind of girl like know
okay so he could be broke and play xbox
all day what he could be broke and play
xbox all day
okay well part of someone's personality
is being
driven or like working hard
so i hate it when guys make it seem like
money because it's not always about i
know where they're going with this and
they're going to say it's about money
and it's not necessarily always about
money it's about being
useful and driven and working hard
but like if someone wanted to be a coach
i always say this if someone wanted to
be a coach
and they were like driven and passionate
about what they were doing but maybe
don't make the most amount of money
like i wouldn't care it's about like
work ethic he definitely needs to be
ambitious because he's very ambitious
so like i definitely can't be like
someone who's broke someone who like
doesn't try hard at all like someone who
genuinely like you know
works um and you know tries to make a
living
um someone with integrity who is honest
with me i think honesty is like
the most like underlooked um value
a lot of people like to lie and i'm just
like i'd rather be straight up
so definitely honesty i'll give you that
for now and then we can talk about okay
we should
we should have phrased the question
correctly how tall does he have to be
and how much money does he have to earn
per year
um most of the guys that i've like been
with have been like at least
close to six foot or over six foot okay
how much do they earn per year annual
i've actually never asked that question
okay but what kind of lifestyle would
you say
they're they're living um
above average above average upper middle
class you would say yeah
so maybe 100 000 a year eighty thousand
dollars a year fifty thousand dollars a
year
oh in college
i literally just graduated college but
like a hundred thousand
okay that's what they're the guys that
you date with their
100 000 is upper middle class what
give or take what they're making yeah
okay fair enough um okay what about you
miss canada
what do you look for in a guy what are
the uh height
earning etc uh taller than me
um and i'm like way too nice i guess i
i'll date guys who aren't
making tons of money but as long as
they're ambitious at least that was me
before now i'm like
you need to at least like really have
your [ __ ] together because i feel like
i need that okay i've needed some real
bumps though you have
oh yeah and you broke up with them after
yeah i didn't know they were such a
bombing
you know like in there because they're
like straight fraud so they tricked you
yeah but i've also dated some you know
very wealthy people so i've experienced
both
but definitely i look for people who are
honest um integrity is really big for me
as well
i agree with what janelli said it's
really hard to find people who are like
actually who they say they are i've
experienced a lot of men who
just front like a lot yes i talk about
this a lot
you never really know how much money
someone's making
because a lot of people make a lot of
money but they also spend a lot of money
so if you're dating somebody that has no
money skills and like they're not
putting away
20 of their income or even 10 that's
probably better than most people
like it's not always about how much
money you make it's about how much money
you save
that's 100 and that's always really
disappointing
um but yeah i like funny dudes
i like people who are entrepreneurs
because i'm an entrepreneur myself
and i feel like i need somebody who has
that hustle mentality so that they'll
understand that
i'm not interested in just sitting and
watching movies with you if we're not
really like trying to make money
together or
help each other grow then i'm probably
gonna like
keep it moving okay yeah so let me ask
you this for a one-night stand
what does he have to have a box a really
nice body
a nice body okay okay and well okay like
he doesn't have to be like
all the way crazy fit or anything like
that but i think you know there's a
certain vibe that i definitely go for
um if he's you know making me feel sexy
and he's hitting on me and he's flirting
and he's you know like put in the effort
to
plan a date take me out he made a rezzo
like he did all those little steps that
it like impresses me
i'm like oh this man he like he tried
you know like
there's something to be like let's go to
the beach and they'll just like
literally show up with nothing and then
there's guys who will be like with a
picnic blanket
and wine and that guy's way more likely
to get laid but i'm not really a huge
one-night stand person either i'm more
of like a
third third date because i like to make
sure people are who they say they are
first like i want to see your house i
want to know like
you have a job and all those things so
you drag a guy out on three dates
yeah of course
wait three dates that's a long time
what what if you don't even if you've
never met a guy you've hung out with him
three times
when she was going at the beginning i
was like okay i'm trying for you then
you want like your own pal
yeah no you can't have all this good
stuff unless
i verify you first okay okay all right
so uh the read so so how much money did
i have to earn i need a tangible number
here
per year i never really asked but i
would say that yeah i need to see that
you have a house that's nice
decent you have furniture you have a bed
frame
i call it the girlfriend janelly knows
about the girlfriend but i know the back
story you know um
you know i need to uh you have a car
you don't need to be making like
millions of dollars or anything like
that but you need to have a career and
you need to take it seriously you need
to be successful
can you give us a number please
i'll go with canadian because i'm so
nice oh canadians that's what you know
isn't it we're in canada
okay let's bump it up to 100 then 100
canadian okay so 108 canadian about uh
like what 80 80k u.s yeah i'm also at
the age now where it's like
i'm not really just like frivolously
dating people because i just don't feel
like i have time for that
so unless you're like you're in a more
serious stage of your life how old do
you know i'm 33
33 yeah i wouldn't say i'm like she's
33.
dang she looks good curious but if i'm
gonna mess with you
then i want you to be serious about your
own life
okay you know and i could tell she had
some fun in the past
yeah shout out to all my canadians in
there okay and then uh super chats real
quick because i know they're gonna start
piling up
um okay uh kyle demito uh five dollars
just focusing on
my money slash crypto most of these
women are just smashing dash
good for you i'm on my crypto and focus
on my money too
there you go there you go
it's like the masculine energy that they
always talk about
uh use this money to buy a prize for the
fastest lie in
fnf history thank you so much
[Music]
yeah we have a lie detector that's why
yeah put me on it yeah
let's do it okay well freshly supposed
to learn how to use it first do you
learn how to use it yet polygraphy baby
i kind of understand a bit nothing is
no trim on the second date and shoddy
gots to skate
okay i never said i won't fool around i
just
you know don't always give them the box
okay okay
but she said always so that means she
will for real
okay uh nadia nadia so me um
remind me of the questions again so uh
what do you look for in a guy
and let's say for example on a one-night
stand or a relationship
and then six feet and how tall would it
have to be how much money
they have to make like that okay so one
night stan
it has to be the vibe he has to look
good
there you go yeah there you go pretend
it's a penis wait wait what
um it has to be a vibe he has to look
good i guess um
honestly i'm gonna keep it real with you
guys it depends on how much money he
spends that night
or in miami okay okay um where are we at
what's the vibe are we in a club are we
out to eat like how much did he spend
tonight that's how you're gonna get your
one-night stand i guess someone is
keeping it giving it rich
yeah we have to um that's how i go based
off of because it's like you know
time is money attention is money sex i
value my vagina so it's like okay well
you're not gonna get a one-night stand
if you
you know what i'm saying you might as
well just be a prostitute then
it doesn't equate somebody but it kind
of does we're in miami
um we're in miami is miami like a
different
world i don't i don't get it
it's not lifestyle so yeah i'm not gonna
[ __ ] a broke guy but i can tell off the
rip if he's broke or not and that's why
i go based off of
what do we do you can't always you can't
some people make a lot of money but they
spend more than they have
today for you to say that you're gonna
get some [ __ ] you know best
um yeah we're gonna do that like that uh
height
i've never really been one for a height
i'm like five six almost
he can't be shorter than me so like five
nine and up i'm pretty generous you know
the guys
i've learned you know sometimes when
they're smaller they have bigger dicks
so you know and they know what they do
they're doing with it because they're
you know they're more humble and they
have to kind of like
to make up for it they have to make up
for it so oh [ __ ]
y'all guys got a chance i didn't see
that that was too fast
oh no we'll read them don't worry want
to make sure you finish just focus on
um as far as the relationship goes once
you know i'm living a lifestyle right
now that i'm young i'm having fun
you know it's like how old are you by
the way i'm 24 24 okay so i want to be
young i want to have fun and so it's
going to be it's going to be like the
biggest brightest prize obviously that's
gonna win and guys do the same thing
guys they're gonna go after the girls
who have the best bodies or who have the
you know what i'm saying like guys are
gonna go after the same exact thing so i
feel like in this age i can go after
that too
um as far as a relationship in which i
have been in relationships before
i'm not in one now but um as far as
relationships i think that's when you
start to look at people's values and
their morals and
their education and their definitely
their income i make an income myself
so i expect your income to be at least
my income
but you know you're not supposed to get
with somebody can you give us a number
for my income yeah no for like what the
guy has or not you oh the guy's income
yeah what does he have to earn honestly
to really you know the thing i've
learned in life is that there's a whole
bunch of guys who
well i mean it depends if i'm really
[ __ ] with him or if i'm really just
trying to [ __ ] with him and those are
two different things
i don't know if that makes sense but
those are two different things yeah okay
well to smash him and then to date him
seriously well like i said to smash him
he has to spend some money
okay so he's got to be earning like at
least six figures a year oh yeah yeah
yeah
he's gotta have some money uh side note
i am from boston so
the you know the price of the cost of
living everything yeah costs a lot more
money
well you live here at miami i live here
give us the miami prices
miami is full of people who get money
and they don't want to spend it so i'm
going hard on miami people but
um if he's if he's taking him so
seriously if he has a goal if he has a
hobby
or something that if i can believe in
him like you have to have like a plan so
if i can see your plan and i can believe
in it i watch you doing your
i talk about this a lot women it's not
always about
the guy that like has the most money but
it's the guy with a plan that's
ambitious 100 yeah he's gonna get some
leeway
but you know sometimes you know you got
to start somewhere you can't just we're
getting older too so it's like you can't
give us a number a number i love how you
guys just like dance around the question
and then try to give us something oh he
wanted the number hard numbered
sometimes it just depends on the dude
like
how he makes you feel like that
sometimes it's worth more than if he
makes 100 200k
you know and if you know you can see
that he's like growing well that's
exactly why we set for a one-night stand
and then for a relationship
that's why we had a two-part question
and when i stand he's spending some
[ __ ] money
okay for the relationship we're gonna
say like um it
depends on the cost of living and where
you're at okay miami i'll be generous
i'm gonna say like at least i mean i'm
gonna say six figures but six figures
okay it goes from a hundred thousand
dollars to 999 000 so like i'd say to be
fair maybe we'll say like
175 175 in miami okay
what about boston just out of curiosity
oh boston um
it's a little a lot a bit more but you
also have people who are doing different
things out here
it's a fast life so i expect a little
bit i expect a little bit more just
because of the fast life and i
understand so 175k here at what quarter
mill in boston maybe
if i'm going to get married yeah i mean
if it's you're going to take the guys
seriously yeah oh i mean anybody that
i'm going to take seriously we're
talking about serious serious you have
to make i mean
i can't even be unfair i guess i don't
know i can't put a number on i don't
think that's fair all right correct no
real talk man but basically six figures
so many troops there
guys what do we say all the time they
won the highest bidder
facts what do you say on the show all
the time big facts i know you can't
believe
all right i'm gonna like
let's see the wage gap myth i'm gonna go
a little back on this skip a little
forward
just because guys this is three and a
half hours you will not catch me
watching this whole thing
no pause on that i mean i mean i'll just
keep her stack with you most women are
awful of money if we're going to be
honest
about it you know true true
there are girls on like tick tock or
whatever
and okay if they get like clothes sent
to them from brands that's one thing but
like i don't know how these girls afford
like new clothes all the time especially
when shit's like
50 100 bucks an like article of clothing
this is why i'm cheap i do not
i hate spending money a little bit three
quarters of debt
to this michael how dare you no it's
literally proven absolutely it's
statistically known exactly
like women yeah three quarters of the
world's debt is held by women and
most colleges held by
exactly so so in general most women are
battle with money now does that mean
that all women are financially
illiterate and stupid no not at all no
but i am saying that there's a large
amount of
joy with money yeah uh so anyway because
we don't get taught
how to handle it we just get taught that
we're supposed to find a man with money
to take care of us
who teaches you that i would argue it's
the opposite no
we're definitely changing no i would
argue now that the narrative is like
social media
only fans it's not an end-all be-all
come on now it's not but it's
it's a start i would say that the strong
babes like a
shortcut that's going to like haunt you
potentially forever
and in today's day and age like with
with modern feminism and everything like
that like i i feel women are taught
not even i feel i know women are taught
strong be strong and independent don't
rely on a guy go out there and go to
school
yeah that that is a narrative for a lot
of women um that's why it's really
important to have a good like support
structure at home
and like women that you can actually get
advice from
like the one thing that i've learned the
older i get is i would never take advice
from someone i wouldn't want to trade
places with so if like the woman you're
taking advice from
isn't in a position that like you would
want to be in
like i don't know if you're trying to
get your advice somewhere else
get your bag 60 over 60 of college
attendees are women but then we graduate
and we get paid less
but whose choice is that though no
that's by the employers who devalue
women's
value like are you saying that women get
paid less yeah like
i do not i have never bought into the
wage
gap i've never bought into it when i
worked in a sales job i got so many more
favors i got the best territory like
because i was the only girl in the
office like
i guarantee they're about to i bet you
they're about to like bring in some
facts because
that's not true 20 to 30 percent left
okay
oh i guess we're entering the wage gap
myth
so because of oh it's a myth yeah it's
100
a myth yes so i'll break this down real
quick
when they when they say oh women earned
70 cents or not i've been there
or 80 cents on every dollar that's false
the reality is this
the reason why women get paid less is
because they tend to work less hours
take more vacation time paternity and
they also
lead all the industries that pay the
least by choice they go into social work
they go into jobs that end up paying
less math
science um and engineering these types
of jobs pay a lot more
that's where the men go and women go to
college more than men so there's no
argument about like oh they don't have
the same opportunity no no no
the there's the equality of opportunity
it's just that women want equality of
outcome and that's not the way the world
works
so the thing is is that and on top of
that too one last thing
men also work far more dangerous jobs
that pay more than women do
law enforcement drilling construction
alaskan fishing
glass ceiling and we'll just knowledge
real quick
but i'm smart you know what i'm saying
so there's a part where it's like okay
but um
if you have to say i'm smart you're
probably not as smart as you think
like smart people don't have to go
around saying that they're smart
there's opportunity being a man gives
you more opportunity yeah um you can be
a woman and you can go into an interview
and a man will hire a man just because
he's a man before you as a woman who has
way more credentials
for that job before he has a manager
because he can relate to him on that
level okay
i do agree with what you say when you
say that women go after less paying jobs
and what i will say is that women don't
know how to negotiate their pain they
don't know that's true
that is a part of why they make less
because they're like they're more they
tend to be
they're just going to take what they get
because like oh my god i got this job
you know it starts checking i think we
are changing the narrative now
but also too i think women need to
understand that like go where their
money's paying you like know what you're
worth too like if a [ __ ] [ __ ] if it's
only fans
you're gonna make 20k 30k on only fans
what the [ __ ] what what are you working
a nine to five for
i will say this though because the glass
ceiling is also a myth uh because
okay i'll tell you why it's a myth but
all the industries
that uh women claim that there's a glass
ceiling in there and
they're actually incentivized to hire
more women right but you could say same
thing and push them up
you can say the same thing when they did
um affirmative action that's why but
women benefit it was bad
but it's just now happening it was in
like the last 15 years okay but we're
talking
we're talking about right now two
thousand it in 2021 yeah
women have more privileges and rights
than men do absolutely just because you
have to fill that gap that was for so
long
holding over women that's the only
reason why and then
did you know that women didn't even want
the right to vote
like the majority of women didn't even
want it nothing's as simple
as people make it out to be when they
say arguments like that i was becoming a
thing it's become like oh it's all right
i would say we're over corrected now
there are more women in college
there are more women uh in in the
working now than men are
uh women are earning men in a lot of the
major cities the united states we're
still folding your laundry and cooking
your dinner and having your babies i'm
arguing that they're not doing that
they're they're not at all
what the career thing really yeah i'll
say this i'll say this
the glass ceiling also a myth because
like i said the jobs that
used to ostracize women from the
workplace now are incentivizing women to
come in
if you're in the military or you're in
law enforcement or you're like in the
business setting as a woman
you're way more likely to get promoted
and get a job based on affirmative
action and also them having
equal opportunity if you're a minority
female even more and this is the
uncomfortable reality you guys want to
know who's getting ostracized white men
yeah we're going to get out but i think
that women should stop their
husband in general because they think
there's places that women make tons of
money like i have guys tell me all the
time like
oh my god you just sit there and you
just walk around you bring bottles you
just sit here and you dance with guys
and you get all this money and it's like
yeah you can't do that
so i feel like it could we have to kind
of start like gloves
no no okay i get the gist of that let's
try different part
[Music]
um
business plan that sounds interesting
you put us in a woman's body i'll be
millionaires
i'll be ten times over give me one year
and a woman's body i'll be
a hot woman i guarantee they mean a hot
woman a millionaire in a year it's a
wrap
but how would you get there yeah okay
well you want to focus down
yeah so this is what i'll do i wake up
tomorrow i'm you you know what i would
do
okay i might hurt your feelings a little
bit but i'm gonna say it all right i'll
go to the gym
i'd slim down a bit right because you
have a look that would be appealing to a
large demographic of men with the
mulatto skin right yeah
then i would uh make an only fans i'd
get on patreon
and i'd also uh start playing video
games yep i'd have the niche of gamer
girl
on twitch yes and i'd be playing video
games on twitch i'd be using
putting cosmo pictures up on patreon and
then i'd have my explicit content and
only fan so i can hit every single tier
of man that wants to deal with me
then i'd also be uh dancing right as
well at night and
working a couple times that would be
where my predominant income would come
from stripping
yeah okay that would be stripping uh
because that's where my predominant
money would come from and then i would
slowly get off of that and move on to
the online world but i have to build a
following for myself so being in the
club networking with other men with men
networking with girls building my social
media then once i have that established
i start funneling them all
over to my paid content through patreon
twitch and uh only fans
which goes up in tier as far as like the
explicity
and then uh i can appeal to the gamer
guys here on one side with this niche
then i can also go on only fans for guys
that want to see me like
play with the dildo whatever and i do
that for a year earning
you know easily you can easily earn 20
to 50k a month doing that if you do it
right
yep bam i'd be i'd be a millionaire or
i'd be very close to it and i'd take
that money and start investing into
other things but if i was a girl i'd be
killing it especially with these sims
let me answer that as well so i would
also have three sugar daddies
oh yeah i forgot about what one payment
rent this is terrible advice
this is terrible advice for women that's
not a career
one paying for all my all my all my
other expenses and then one just give me
money
just just because i'd also have my own
website for my own product so for
example
you got yeah you could add only fans
page and all that stuff as well
but i want to have my own platform so
that whatever happens i also have a
backup
and then when i'm gonna name it from
those platforms which is all my content
uh explicit non-explicit i'm gonna put
that into real estate and invest i now
sell feet picks too yeah i
forgot about the the um
that's also like selling your soul but
what do i know the thing about like um i
would also cuddle
right because cuddling makes a lot of
money you say all this [ __ ] but you
don't want to do all that
like why do you have to tell your body
to actually become a millionaire i'm
gonna do it for a period of time then
i'm done yeah but you don't get it your
reputation is on the line
yeah yeah and look at how men judging
[Music]
whoa did we not talk about how we would
make money in a year exactly yeah
that's one year and then i'm done but
that's not realistic
yo do you know you're selling your
dignity
yeah a lot of girls do that you're
sacrificing so much
you have to sell your soul to all these
dirty gross men who want to like
when you're done you're set though see
see here's the problem right you're
thinking about oh how am i gonna look
i'm gonna come
on how am i going to look but when
you're done you're done okay
what about me what about me like i'm a
designer interior designer
hold on again again i'm going to stop
you ladies the conversation was get your
feelings out of it the conversation was
how are we going to make a million
dollars in a year as a woman we just
described it to you so you have to sell
your [ __ ]
no you don't have to we're just we said
we were having sex with men foreign
that is not that is not foreign
live viewers right now holy [ __ ] shout
out to the chat would you guys subscribe
to my only fan
there you go i'll just like dance around
and rub my titties and give you guys
tips on how to make your house look cute
okay ten dollars peter delore girl on
the right gives me good vibes call it a
hunch uh or i'm stupid anyway shameless
shout out it's my birthday can i get it
done to marco sherlock there you go
happy birthday okay
this was interesting i'm gonna cut it
there this is an interesting
debate like honestly that i don't think
that's a good idea though to tell like
young women
that's a good idea to like sell your
body
because there's repercussions one for
your soul and
two like what kind of hus like
you're gonna have a lot a lot harder of
a time finding a husband after that
so i don't know just my two cents let me
know in the comments do you think i'm
right do you think i'm wrong
um and let me know what videos i should
react to next i'm trying to react to a
lot more videos
in the next couple weeks so i will talk
to you guys next time